what is the largest country in south
america in south america
africa we're talking about
cyber security today and how safe
people's passwords are
what is one of your online passwords
currently it is my dog's name
and the year i graduated from high
school what kind of dog do you have i
have a chival of papillon
and what's its name jamison jamison and
where'd you go to school
um i went to school back in greensburg
pennsylvania what school hempfield area
senior high school oh when did you
graduate in 2009
oh great it's a big hop-up issue right
now in the environmental community are
the homo sapiens worth saving
what's your take
yes why is that just
because there's a lot of animals that
are extinct now that
were amazing back in the day about like
like dinosaurs they extinct
and someday we can look back and be like
oh we didn't save them
the homo sapiens right yeah so we didn't
save them so
like maybe they could be like the next
dinosaur because the dinosaurs
hunted they killed each other and other
creatures so
so you're saying let's not let the homo
sapiens become like the dinosaurs
kinda if you met some people from
denmark what are they what would they be
called
denmark a group of people in denmark
would be
called jewish people jewish people
can you name any country on this map
honestly my geography's so horrible
i can't eat anything like nothing
is it south africa nope name as many
avengers as you can
it's many avengers captain america
hawkeye the hulk
um iron man black widow
name as many us presidents as you can
[Music]
see where you get them um see
obama george washington
um
[Music]
wow what does canada have to benefit now
that they're going to be a 51st state
uh our freedoms and um
one other thing about america uh our
guns
um any country i mean i know
um this is so horrible where's america
i would say this big one but i'm
probably wrong
okay what countries make up great
britain
you've heard of great britain yeah if
someone said they're going to great
britain what language would they speak
when they get there
british they speak british okay have you
ever met anyone who speaks
british no can you think of any word
british
um no no mini cooper
oh yeah mini cooper do you think moving
independence day
is insulting to our forefathers
alexander p
keaton jack carter joseph gordon-levitt
reginald bell johnson i would suggest so
i i mean i would i
i think they signed it on that day you
know because that was the time
for it that was the best time can you
name any country in europe
is this one europe no there's one right
now
um can you name a single country in
africa
[Music]
was this africa south america
no idea can you name a country in south
america
okay this is south america yes can you
name a country in it
no i can't did you go to high school yes
did you go to college
yeah that's the sad part can you name a
book
oh yes
i don't read books but um what's it
called
um
[Music]
indiana no
i don't know almost
i do no closer
i don't i don't know say it really fast
i don't know i don't i don't know say
i'm confused
this is hard i'm not a hoe
huh
can you name a book
no how many stars on the flag
32 there's a flag right up there see
that one
how many stars on that flag it's moving
too fast to count them
what was the last book you read um
probably dr zeus
dr seuss dr seuss dr
seuss maybe um i haven't read a book for
like 12 years
i'm drawing a blank um
jeez i need books um
sorry i am totally blanking out on books
what do you do for a living
i was a librarian
you guys are graduating high school this
week no it's june 16th june 16th so you
should know a lot of stuff
but we know a lot what is our galaxy
called
[Music]
i am it's also a candy bar
mars what was your reaction when you
learned that katy perry had trademarked
the word
fireworks and now people have to refer
to them specifically as sky
sparkles i don't i don't really think
that it's
it's fair i think because we've known
them as fireworks thus far
and i think that we're gonna keep that
name
fireworks because that's what we've
always gone by fireworks
now um sky sparkles i think that's a
phenomenal name but i don't think a lot
of us
will resort to that name i'm sure you
heard donald trump came out and said
white people should celebrate on the 4th
of july black people on the 5th and
mexicans on february 29th
is that fair that mexicans only get to
celebrate once every four years
no i think everyone should be free to
celebrate
whenever they want i mean it's america
if you want to celebrate the 4th of july
go for it we're all here
to have a good time respect each other
heard donald trump say that
yeah i heard it about on the radio well
thanks for watching
name as many avengers as you can oh
captain america
thor hulk uh
black widow hawkeye
uh scarlet witch uh
quicksilver um
iron man uh
i think that's it is that it okay
name as many us presidents as you can uh
grover washington can you name
any country on this map
yeah africa that's a continent
oh god can you name any countries in
africa
god no who knows stuff like that what do
you think
founding father nathan phillian meant
when he said give me liberty or give me
a break
hashtag castle uh well i think we need
to have our freedom we had
we need to have our independence or else
we become heavy with burdens and we
don't have liberty
did you learn about that quote in school
yeah i remember more than college so
when it became more relevant we had
our independence to think of what it
meant to us individually do we have hold
up for a second i just want to sync up
my watch real quick is that the right
time
eventually all right happy hour
hey which is bigger the sun or the moon
hmm it could be a trick question what's
your moon
which we have a lot of them no we only
have one moon it's not us personally
i'm not talking about owl i'm not
talking about rigel 7 or star trek 9.
our moon which is bigger the sun or the
moon
the sun's light radius or an actual
which is a bigger which is bigger
physically bigger the sun or the moon i
would say
the moon yeah because i think it's a
trick question yeah i would say the man
put your corn in the donut put your corn
in the donut yes sir and move it back
and forth
we're talking with lindsay shanks
lindsey and your high school student as
well
yes sir what is the world's tallest
mountain
it's not mount rushmore no no
do you ever rest do i what ever rest
no i'm giving that skill oh
i really don't know yeah i asked you do
you ever rest then you say oh not
everybody
where were you when you found out the
news that canada is becoming a state i
was drinking coffee at starbucks
and watching in my phone social media
and stuff
so i was like wow that's very shocking
were other people watching it in
starbucks yeah they actually were
and now they were actually some were
like kind of mad because i heard them
cursing
and then the other ones were laughing
another one's just shocked it sounds
like chaos
it kind of felt like but everybody's
drinking coffee at the same time
where did you watch the coin toss where
donald trump chose between puerto rico
and canada
i was actually at that point at home you
know and drinking coffee
you know and uh that almost spit the
coffee out
so i thought it was so hilarious yeah so
it was pretty funny
can you describe it to people who've
never seen it uh yeah he he he was like
all's nice smooth with his suit with the
power tie
then he just went boom with one hand and
it went up
i don't know i lost count how many times
it went up and then went back into it
down so it was pretty funny welcome
canada and let's make canada great again